[Music]
ann is in columbia south carolina
starting off this hour hey anne what's
up
cj it's good to talk to you you too
um
i haven't
i don't know what to do
my husband just died within the last
week or so oh my and
and
i went to call my sister only to find
out that her husband had died in
february
so
my
sounding board
were both in the same boat
but the reason i called is because i
don't know exactly
what i should be doing in terms
of
the mortgage
i
received a
letter from the mortgage company where
they were doing the annual escrow
analysis
and they've upped the mortgage payment
almost a thousand dollars
and how old are you
76
how old was your husband
85
what happened
he fell at home and
he went to the va hospital and they in
turn transferred him to a
civilian hospital and seven days later
he died they don't know exactly why he
died they were guessing
they initially admitted him to a
co-reward
and
then a day and a half later they changed
him to a regular ward
but
hospital they called the psychiatrist
called it a hospital psychosis
he just really
um
he tore his clothing off the
tourists
medical devices off and uh
just with a
saying
i'm sorry not some nice thing
what was his name
monroe so do you have children
he has three grown children
i have three grown children they're all
on their own
okay which one of your three children is
the responsible one
my daughter
didn't take didn't take long to come up
with that name call her today okay
well
i thought about that when i first heard
about your daughter and tell her
and tell her you need some help
okay because you're sounding bored the
sounding board you used to use we're
gonna change out for your daughter okay
okay she's gonna be your sounding board
we're gonna help you too we're not gonna
leave you okay
but i need her in your life walking with
you
as you start making these different
decisions because one week after your
husband passes and you all were married
for many many years is not a good time
well actually it was a
it was a third marriage for both of us
and
we had been married for 15 years many
years yeah
and so it's a tough day it's a tough
week it's a tough year for you and i
don't want you making big financial
decisions like the lone ranger right now
the lone ranger even needed tonto
okay so let's get your we're gonna get
her in your corner i'm also gonna when
we get through i'm gonna put you on hold
and i'm gonna have one of our coaches
ramsay coaches that are certified by us
help you
walk you through the financial details
of this and we're not gonna charge you a
dime it's going to be completely free
okay
wow thank you okay
so we've got to make sure that because i
don't want something like an escrow
account that could just be messed up
to throw you into a tizzy and cause you
to sell a house while you're in the
midst of this grief
because it's hard to think clear right
now if i'm you anyway
you're right
you just don't know which way to
turn
is there was there a life insurance
policy and is the house in your name are
you able to stay where you are is what
i'm getting at
um
it was a
rite of survivorship so it's out of the
estate
the state doesn't affect it
and uh
are you going to be able to buy
groceries on monday
yeah i guess
i don't need a lot since i'm do you have
money do you have money
do you have money
i i i think i think i think i do
okay so here here's what the first
things we need to do
is to make sure that you got these four
walls taken care of that you've got food
that you can keep the lights on and the
water running you gotta
some kid isn't gonna come knock on the
door one of his children and say that's
my house now and your name's not on the
deed so that i want your daughter and
the coaches will walk you through this
but your daughter's gonna help you with
the basics because that's gonna help you
sleep
okay
and when you don't know where i'm gonna
get groceries if there is a life
insurance policy that i'm supposed to
get somewhere when you don't know those
things it is scary scary scary on top of
this tragic loss
right
right well it was totally unexpected
that's right
we had talked about rehab and going to
that and the things he needed to do in
order to get there and yeah
it sounds like it sounds like it's out
of the blue and
that those that first six months that
first year that first two years can be
an absolute
black fog yeah and that's why you gotta
have someone you love walking next to
you yeah call your daughter as soon as
you hang up with us
and then we will have one of our coaches
call you
within 24 hours and we'll make sure
you've got food money set up and we'll
make sure that you've got a good budget
and you got a good handle on where you
are somebody walking with you and
helping you do this stuff and again we
don't need any payment from this this is
uh
my bible says to take care of widows and
that's what i'm doing so um and it's our
honor to do that for you so you hang on
and jenna will pick up and we'll get you
connected up with a um
with a coach to help you walk through
this and um
because you're
when you get some of the basics done
like john is saying and you lay that
you know food is okay and you know the
lights and water is okay and you know i
got a place to live suddenly it helps
your mind start to clear because right
now it's all jumbled up and it's uh like
you're juggling flaming swords in your
head or something and i'm i'm gonna lean
in and say that her her husband did this
i want every husband listening to this
call to hear that voice
if you don't have a will
if you have not sat down with your wife
and said here's where this stuff is
here's what the here's what happens next
here's where the paper is in where the
drawer is where the paper is
listen to her voice i don't know if i've
got food next week
do not be that husband yeah
and why by the way wives those of you
that are handling the money your husband
doesn't know what's going on same goes
for you
you guys get on the same page and have a
plan
hang on jen i'll pick up and we'll take
care of you anne